the Joe Rogan experience so you said
what's a little disingenuous about the
film they said every plant has every
amino acid
well yeah nobody disagrees with that but
it does have does it have enough of each
of them well first of all people do
disagree with that but if you want to
search does you know plants of missing
amino acids people think that it's
missing some of the Niners and
communities so that's why we put that in
the film okay and we did and I said you
left off part of my coil I said every
plant has every amino acid that's what
you said but you left off the end of my
quote which said every plant has every
amino acid in varying proportions that
is what I said and you left out the in
varying proportions which again I think
is disingenuous he did not complete my
quote you hand-picked part of my quote
to represent your view so people
remember one do think that plants are
completely minute so a lot of people
think just like you know that people
that there's articles saying when no one
thinks that protein gives them energy
I've got five studies here the only five
states that I could find on the
knowledge of collegiate athletes and
around 50% in each of the studies think
that protein is what gives you energy
so people were saying like why did you
put that in the film that's a straw man
people don't think the protein gives the
energy about 50% of collegiate athletes
think that protein gives energy that's
why I dressed in the film anyway back to
you like the DIA is Right the distr
Jesta Belinda's pencil amino acid scroll
or the pdcaas which preceded it yeah
either of those right so can you can you
just mention why you like it and you
know what the benefits are and how it's
the term how is it determined so the
benef the das takes into consideration
amino acid profile and bioavailability
and how is it study I did not take into
consider it looks at crude protein to
the total amount of protein absorption
not the individual amino acids because
different comedo in different and mean
different individual amino acids absorb
differently so that was one of the
benefits of the DES scoring record the
Assam PD case or whatever so but how is
it determined Chris you know how it's
determined the DES yeah I don't know the
details
I'm sorry I'm sorry it's like it's just
it's like it's almost like a comedy that
someone is talking about these systems
that does not know how to sew slide 27
and I'll tell you one of the benefits of
the DIA is so and I think you might have
mentioned this so I think you might know
more than you're letting on so one of
the benefits is the auro ileal
digestibility so the pdcaas right that
took the whole digestive tract to what
came out will end are we looking at here
so look at this so this is how the dia s
is brought about so basically past the
ileum you can't a digest your boy didn't
absorb the protein really suggested by
the bacteria right so this is one of the
benefits of the dia s versus the pdcaas
right the old system is that they saw
how much protein went through the whole
digestive tract but that wasn't
reasonable right because it passed the
ileum you're not digesting the protein
the bacteria dressing and you're not
getting it and that makes sense yes so
basically they put a poor in the pig now
pdcaas was mostly in rats and this is
that in rats and there's some in humans
but it's mostly done in pigs because
it's a more similar digestibility to
humans and they basically assessing how
much of that protein was absorbed right
and how much of the amino acids were
absorbed now some people make the
argument even the FAO point out the
flaws some people make the argument well
pigs have a different digestibility rate
which is true and they have a different
amino acid profile requirement different
so some people say therefore do a bunch
of crap right I'm not going to make the
argument even though it's 10 animals
primarily not in humans they've got a
different amino acid requirement and
different digestibility capability okay
so I mean dude would you think of that
score is the best one to use measurement
it doesn't make sense right but I'm not
gonna even make that argument I'm gonna
go with you and say okay D s is the best
thing out there okay okay so even though
you can question it so you've said this
is a quote from the last time when you
were trying to bash the film it's all
about protein quality and this as you
said is an established science a firmly
established science who's talking to you
obviously then you must have said it was
established they look at this especially
in like third world countries where
protein deficiency is common so they try
to figure out how to address this okay
now the FAO the food
agricultural organization of the United
Nations what is their purpose correct
to prevent nutrient deficiency thank you
very much yeah so I've got a slide if
you want to prove but it's basically
defeating hunger providing food security
not for America or for England but for
like the nation you know the like 130
130 countries right where people are
starving malnutrition that is their
purpose so you've got a look at it
through the lens of that so if you just
watch slide 29 because I just want to
bring back these claims up I know the
slides are getting kind of boring I've
been apologized to people just listening
series focusing on protein malnutrition
was largely conducted after the
identification of local kwashiorkor and
the realization that many children
globally are suffering from the
subclinical protein malnutrition to a
jet address protein malnutrition the
composition and digestibility of
proteins must be determined as we go to
the next slide and this is by aura that
was looking at the vs score you can see
at the top Canada di score decreased
protein malnutrition then we go onto say
food and agricultural organization of
the United Nations has developed methods
to evaluate the protein quality of food
items and in 2011 the digestible
indispensable amino acids chordee IaaS
was recommended as a successor to the
previous their previous method okay so
we're not in a disagreement right now
I'm even gonna forego like I'm not gonna
argue about the animal having different
amino acid quirements or even though
that's like that's pretty funny right
like why are you assessing anyway so I'm
not gonna have that argument what I'm
gonna have is I'm gonna go with
everything so far
FAO they're endorsing it over the pds a
lot of experts endorsing over dia okay
over the PD cast okay
so now in slide 31 it's made for
starving children okay mmm-hmm this is
what it's made for so I would agree if
you're in a caloric deficit and you're
in a country where there's very little
protein and you've only getting 30 grams
of protein a day let's just say that the
animals like take the animal stuff out
of it and like the way that the method
is flawed
over to the FAO points out yeah so let's
just say it's legit I would agree I
would say get
protein from me I would agree because
that's what it was designed for as you
can see in looking at our post exercise
skeletal muscle the dia s does not
attempt to consider how scores translate
into optimizing more downstream
physiological targets of interest to a
physically active personal athlete so it
wasn't designed for that system it was
designed for starving people in
countries where they were not getting
enough protein and they weren't getting
enough protein as you would call high
quality okay so so would you recognize
that it wasn't developed for that system
yes based on the scientific literature
but you're inferring it now for the
amount that I still think it's a
relevant measure of protein quality
because it is no acid profile and ileal
digestibility yeah it is in starving
countries when people are starving I
agree but as you can see it's still
looking at amino acid profile right do
you concede that it's looking at the at
the relative content of amino acids in a
particular food yes and it's looking at
the ileal digestibility which i think is
an improvement over the I think it's got
elements even though the FAO has point
out is flaws and ten years from now
we'll have a better system right but
right would you agree probably plenty
now probably ever been
assistant-managing okay but it's the
best that it can kind of go of but again
it looks at and it's not just my opinion
that is not used for that this is like
in sports medicine 2019 and I agree
you're busy with other stuff you
probably haven't seen this article that
came out and they'll in February right
have you seen this article or have not
seen take your article so so basically
can you look at the now in the 2018
Journal of international sports of
sports nutrition slide 32 society of
sports nutrition because you like to say
it's what about muscle protein synthesis
right that's an important factor okay it
has been proposed that muscle muscle
protein synthesis is maximized in young
adults with an intake of 20 to 25 grams
of high-quality protein about the scram
about about 20 25 grams of a
high-quality perfect high-quality
okay do you disagree that like eating
four or five times a day at 20 to 25
grams of high-quality protein whey be
whatever you want to take highest or
whatever under your you know the scoring
system you agree with do you agree that
that is the amount to maximize proposal
when it shows that that does for a
four-hour window acute muscle proteins
is this yeah they're most of the sports
organizations suggest that for acute
protein right intake but if you now I
again I'm going with the consensus so if
you take that twenty to twenty-five
times four or five times a day
multiply that what is that that's 80 200
120 grams of protein today is that is
that enough Roberge athlete proteins and
fight is that enough for like a 250
pound athlete I would say no so I'm not
I'm not saying that I do I think you
need more protein than that right so
much muscle protein synthesis is only
one factor right can you tell me what
the other factors are tissue
regeneration and repair recovery right
yeah yeah okay so I think we're on there
on the same page that 20 25 grams has
basically been shown in a single sitting
over a four-hour window in what we call
a cute short term that's been shown to
maximize muscle proteins in this and
that is because 20 grams and it's been
shown actually can get less with like
egg you could get like 17 grams or
something
but especially you're hitting two things
you're hitting leucine you're getting
one point eight to two point one point
eight to two grams of leucine which is
basically like a foreman right it's like
telling the others like hey you should
build protein if you don't have any
leucine and if you add all the essential
amino acid you want except for leucine
you wouldn't have the form and telling
all the workers to like build the muscle
basically that's what leucine is so
you're getting enough leucine and you're
getting eight to ten grams of essential
amino acids that is what is important in
the acute stage of muscle protein since
this you're getting eight to ten grams
of and we can get more granular on like
it's you know point zero grams per pound
of body weight but it's this is
basically accepted and in fact they've
shown that like even if you're 400
pounds
you know you probably you probably don't
need even more than 20 25 grams for some
reason there's something in that number
about getting the leucine amount doesn't
really matter how big you are you know
there's a small presentable
so you might need a bit more 2.5 or
whatever but consensus is this 20 25
grams and I'm sorry this is like long
but it's like it's important to like
breath down okay so so by the way just
going back to your dear scoring you're
basically looking at like a rules for
jiu-jitsu don't like a gay jiu-jitsu
tournament and you're trying to apply
them to MMA so just because jiu-jitsu is
involved in MMA it doesn't mean that a
scoring system for for like IBJJF or
whatever that doesn't mean that that's
the best scoring system for MMA right
that's for sure yeah you could get
points for like yeah yeah whatever
okay so essentially and this isn't just
my opinion okay this is scientific
literature not an article that you just
pulled on is amacom but that's not how
science works you lose Club an article
so slide 33 and it's very clear this is
just very obvious it's not it can't it
cannot just be about short term acute
muscle protein synthesis right it can't
be because you wouldn't be hitting the
1.6 the 2.2 so this states my cute
anabolic responses are not necessarily
associated with long term muscular games
the topic can only be answered by
assessing the results of long digital
studies that directly measure changes in
lean mass with the provision of varying
protein dosages okay so you agree that
it's not just about short term as both
losers okay so what it is Joe it doesn't
matter at a certain point it doesn't
matter because yeah if let's say you
don't have four times a day unless so
you can have a hundred sixty grams of
protein and you have forty grams right
of protein four times a day that's 160
grams so if you're going to optimize
muscle mass and by the way like how much
how much much love you put on in the
last 15 years no I'm not sure man like I
put none right basically I'm about the
same right anyway let's just say that
you're a bodybuilder and you talk about
a stack you trying to stack up as much
muscle as possible because that's like
even like when I get like I'm like 190
193 maybe sometimes like if I go over
200 I just feel slow I feel slow with
the handgun I feel like I just feel
slower plunging like whatever so it's
not everyone's goal is to optimize mass
no mass as quickly as possible
right but let's say that you
all is right clearly it's not enough to
do that you have to hit the one point
six four two point two grams right right
once you hit that amount you have to do
two things you have to hit the muscle
the the short-term leucine threshold and
amino acid in the short-term right and
then you have to hit the so what you
have to do two things you have to
maximize the muscle pose instances in
the short-term and you have to get
enough protein during the day right at
one point six two two point two is that
fair okay so once you hit the one point
six to two point two let's say you have
forty grams it doesn't matter you follow
me you even quoted doesn't matter the
amino acid profile of the food as always
no because as long as you hit the
essential amino acid amount and the
leucine amount in the 410 you can hit
the leucine amount and the amino acid
amount in virtually all of these vegan
forms of protein is a no-no if you
haven't like first of all you could do
it with like if you do beans rice and
vegetables yeah you'd hit two grams of
protein for like five hundred seventy
calories
now again you could like you know that
most athletes supplement right yes like
I can got slides if you want for
scientific proof but you would accept
that like elite athletes but even more
so it's like over percent so people are
suffering with protein powder anyway
they're supplementing with branched
chain amino acids because it contains
lucy nice 3 - yes well over fifty
percent are supplementing with protein
powder and a higher percentage of holies
just athletes period yeah okay and even
more it's probably if your goal is to
like do something and like take creatine
or um you know a protein like you know
these are three key endeavors like you
pointed out the thing that Patrick does
and we can get into right by the way the
misrepresentation of from roller Oh
Hirst burst into his you know Patrick's
records if you want because there was a
lot of claims that were made that were
completely false again so basically if
you get enough protein if you hit one of
the windows if you hit the 1.6 to 2.2
with plant protein you can hit the
muscle protein synthesis and like all of
a sudden he's like oh you're saying
there's no benefit in animal protein for
an amino acid profile versus plant
protein no no no
if you're getting enough protein so
you're saying if you're getting enough
protein
I'm even talking about the ratio of as
you have acknowledged of the right ratio
of plant proteins no no no it's free
it's not difficult at all I'm talking
about leucine if you were like if you
were really messing up and eating like
people just don't eat healthy you might
not get enough leucine but like if
you're planning to become as big and as
strong as possible and your daddy do you
need a specific workout plan but this is
only assuming that you're taking
supplements or Snowdon everyone's taking
achieve no no no no you can do it with
supplements people are taking
supplements now you can do it but are
you assuming that people are taking
supplements no you can do it on a whole
food diet plan with with just food with
b12 like right a supplement b12 nothing
else you can achieve the same amino acid
profile as meat yeah I mean I want to
touch on that I'm not saying that that
is the argument but I just want to throw
people off like depending on where you
live you might want to suffer a vitamin
D based on your son I just wanted like
Dorner like for everybody should do that
anyway and particularly d3 okay so what
I'm saying is as long as you get that
amount of protein in it and again if
you're eating if you're exercising to
optimally build muscle you're exercising
a fair bit right yes you're burning more
calories right right so you eat more
calories and I don't think I don't know
where my sliders we're deep into the
woods here and this is getting really
good but here's the question was but
it's this is what with his assertion was
that the amino acid profile of meat is
superior in context it's important when
you look at the FAO and the goals that
they're doing to try and stop world
hunger it is no important in the Western
world number one and not important if
you're an athlete and hitting the rep
but you're getting between one point six
to two point grams per kilogram so what
you're saying is that as long as you're
getting this one point six to two point
two grams per kilogram yeah of protein
whether it's lentils or peanut butter or
so that you have enough amino acids to
achieve the desired results no and it's
essentially the exact same as if
hitting that 2.2 grams grams it doesn't
matter
do you think that's true if you're
getting 2.2 grams of protein and you're
doing it and you're not doing it in the
way that you said where you're not
planning it and not getting making sure
you're getting enough leucine which is
Lauren you wouldn't have to try I agree
but there's a certain quantity that you
will achieve to Plateau so it doesn't
matter once you've got that amount right
other point that you had about protein
quality is digestibility so that's the
last point that I want to address okay
how am i doing good okay so slide 34
because you basically claim that okay
even if there were enough amino acids
you can't digest it as well more precise
data collected the more precise data
collected so far in humans assessing
real specific oral allele nitrogen
digestibility has shown that the
differences in the digestibility between
plant and animal protein sources are
only a few percent contrary to
historical findings in rats or
determinations using less precise
methods in humans and just so you know I
understand that you haven't seen this
probably because it just came out last
month published by Stanford so I get you
haven't seen it now I'll take this one
step further
there's only at most like two or three
percent different in digestive plant
protein and you know how its assessed in
the pigs they give them raw food so they
give raw beans raw grains and you have
said one of the reasons that it's less
digestible is because of trypsin
inhibitors yeah and what you cook you
would definitely break them down mm-hmm
are you getting it so when you when you
heat food the like here it is you know
it hasn't been tested
we know that the digestibility is less
in plants by a few percent only a few
percent not the forty percent versus a
hundred percent that he was claiming
last time that's old science I'm talking
about current science right and there's
only a few percent difference and they
imagine that not only if you heated it
that you would get equivalent you might
even get more because you'll kill
the trypsin inhibitors by heating it so
that whole nonsense about the the
quantity you were wrong the quality the
di score was not designed for that it
doesn't matter when you get enough
protein so as long as you get enough
protein you're using measures for a
organization that is looking at hunger I
am we're talking about if people have
got enough I agree if you're in like a
developing country and you have very
little diversity of plant foods and
maybe not enough in this manuals you
should be eating the animals I agree but
that is not what it is designed for and
it doesn't matter the amino acid profile
doesn't matter and the digest it doesn't
matter when you get enough protein
[Applause]